when you have a look at this the
question itself says if this and this
are true then find the values of a and B
now there stops short of actually just
labeling for you what kind of a question
this is but there are two equations with
two unknowns
so what category of question is it in
this is simultaneous equations two
equations that are both simultaneously
true
so therefore the very first thing that
we need to do is to be able to talk
about these equations in some way so I
label them right now in the past you've
seen simultaneous equations and they
look like things like this okay so
here's an equation which I've made up
but I've clearly crafted it to lead you
towards a particular method of solution
what do you think I'm trying to lead you
towards I'm trying to lead you towards
solving by elimination because you're
like oh look look at you guys right they
are the same term but opposite sign so I
can just add these two equations
together and I'll eliminate a variable
I'll turn two variables two equations
into one variable one equation yes now
we can apply a very similar concept to
this we just need to tweak it a little
bit right because if you didn't have
exactly the same numbers if you had
something like this so this is not true
anymore I just made a subtle change you
knew that you could use elimination
before you can still use elimination now
but what do you have to do in addition
you can change either of these equations
but in the interest of keeping whole
numbers I'm going to muck around with
this equation and I'm going to double
both sides that will give me a minus 6y
plus 6y and I'm good to go now look
carefully at this one there's index
notation so it kind of disguises a
little bit about what's happening but I
want you to look at these two terms here
or or even these two if you wanted but
this just seals with small numbers
these two are also set up for
elimination we're just one step away
just like that is what could I do to one
of these equations to get these two
marry together today if I multiply by
three
that's all this plus one means by the
way in the index just multiply by three
again so I'm going to take equation one
and I'm going to multiply it by three
right so what this will give me is three
times two da I'm multiplying everything
right three times three to the B and
what's that fifty-one isn't it so you
can see here just a tiny bit of
massaging I'm going to leave this out
the front but this guy here is three to
the power B plus one having gotten this
into a form that I've satisfied is very
very clearly parallel to equation two
I'm going to give it a label that makes
it clear where I got it from and now I
can do elimination just like I would
with any equation I'll go get a fish
this question because I think what you
can see once I put these together what
are we going to get here you're going to
have two to the A plus 2 3 2 to the a
equals 56 how does that look you're
happy with that once I combine these you
can see I just need to use index laws
one more time to make it really obvious
how to get to a right just like this
plus one means multiply that thing by
three again what's this / - mean x -
but-but-but do it twice right if I do it
twice you have four so this is really
four times two to the N is three times
to negate so how many two days do I have
on the left hand side I've seven of them
right four here in tricky
do you want you to continue do you see
where to go from here so you get a
divide both side by 7
you'll get 8 on the right hand side and
8 of course I'm going to convert into
base 2 so it's 2 cubed 2 cubed right so
that is going to give you your value for
a and then off you go back into one of
the original equations to get a value
for B you're happy with that so one of
the classic skills of an extension
student is to be able to look through to
see through a question which looks like
well what on earth does that look like
if you saw this you would have been on
autopilot this is only a little bit
different you used almost that identical
set of skills
it just looks subtly different so that's
why it wasn't as easy to encounter all
right any questions before we move on to
a puppy hmm okay sorry go B now some
people have raised this and I'm going to
ask you if you're in a similar position
to JQ raises to V I'm going to as usual
ask me that I'm going to ask you to
write a note for me so that I can take
this back to the market if appropriate
it says without using a calculator
evaluate so the skill we're looking at
you to demonstrate is can you manipulate
these long terms right so this is what I
want you to consider writing down
the perfect solution for this and
certainly the way that I would have a go
in it because I don't trust my own brain
and I'm told not to use a calculator so
I need to put all the working down here
is that when you see a long term if you
want to get rid of all of this log stuff
you need to be able to compare what are
the bases so what is the basis
relationship to this thing that's inside
the log right base 49 how is it related
to seven
well that seven is the square root of 49
isn't it it's a square root of 49 that's
49 to the power of 1/2 okay so this is
what they're looking for you to
demonstrate here's what's interesting I
wouldn't be that surprise to some of you
saw that that's the square root of 49
and what straits you what will end up
being my next line if that's you can you
write a note for because I'm going to
I'm interested in that we'll see what
happens with that because maybe I can
get a mark for you there same kind of
thing here this is log base 8 of what's
the relationship between 64 and 8 it's a
square okay so at this point you've got
a couple of choices you could just write
it down but it'd be super to make it
super ultra ultra you know clear I'm
going to use my log horse once and then
I'm going to use my log laws again right
do you see how I've used it twice I've
done it here to pull the power out and
make it the coefficient and then here to
say log base a of a is always 1 and
that's where your is not are you happy
with that I think some people want gone
straight here I'll go guarantee anything
but it is I think there's an argument
for whether if you went straight there
you have a mark that you could get which
you didn't get otherwise however I will
point out especially because the
question says without using a calculator
I think for example you have a look at
that I think most of you should be able
to recognize if you know what a log is
and you've been dealing with them since
last year you should be able to
recognize that that is - without using
your cat
later but this makes clear what the
gears are going on in my brain right and
that's the the skill that hasn't been
demonstrated if you went straight to
here is you haven't communicated what's
in your brain does that make sense so
again it's not about ah I lost marks
because I didn't put these lines of work
II it's that you haven't communicated
this working that you actually are doing
in your head okay